[Musique]
est-ce que j'accélère
il n'est jamais là où on attend mais en
tout cas il était avec nous ce matin sur
le plateau de Télématin
la pluie n'aura pas ralenti Charles III
pour sa journée marathon en périple
débuté ce matin au Sénat avec un
discours devant 300 parlementaires
français une première pour un souverain
britannique et l'occasion comme la
veille à Versailles d'exprimer sa
volonté de renforcer l'amitié entre les
deux pays le haut organe qui s'allonge
avec l'âge comme le nez
dans ce 6 heures info bientôt dans 6
heures sur France 2 en ce jeudi 21
septembre bonjour à tous les quatre
promis
pour faire court les pauvres ne savaient
pas
comment je
ne connaissait pas l'intérieur de leur
hôtel